enero de 2016 read anunció a la ruptura
de sus relaciones diplomáticas con
Teherán luego de que manifestantes
iraníes atacaran las misiones
diplomáticas saudíes en Irán tras la
ejecución en el reino de un clérico
disidente
el régimen iraní tiene un largo
historial de violaciones contra misiones
diplomáticas extranjeras como la
ocupación de la embajada estadounidense
en 1979 o el ataque a la embajada
británica en 2011 y finalmente ayer el
ataque contra la embajada Saudita entera
y su Consulado General En massad cuál
actividad
esto provocó el estallido de grandes
manifestaciones en Irán y el
empeoramiento de las relaciones entre
ambos países lo que llevó a Teherán a
acusar a Arabia Saudita de
desestabilizar la región y contribuir a
la propagación del terrorismo
el asesinato de esta persona y el
martirio de esta persona un crimen es un
gran crimen Ya que ellos que toman las
decisiones en el gobierno Saudita no
deberían tener ninguna duda de que esta
sangre les causará problemas
la República islámica y el reino de
Arabia Saudita son las dos potencias más
destacadas de la región el más notable
el de yemen donde era una coalición
militar que apoya al gobierno reconocido
internacionalmente
y acusa a Teherán de apoyar a los
sutiles que controlan grandes áreas en
el norte del país sobre todo
Arabia Saudita también está preocupada
por el programa nuclear de Irán y sus
capacidades de misiles expresa su
preocupación por la influencia Regional
de Teherán y lo acusa de interferir en
Países Árabes como Irak Siria y Líbano